This video is sponsored by Brilliant.
The first 200 to use the link in the description
get 20% off the annual subscription.
September 9th, 1976.
The day, Mao Zedong died, three decades after
founding the People’s Republic of China.
Few countries are so easily divided into two
distinct eras.
With his death, the economic walls around
the Red Dragon slowly fell, allowing the largest
population on earth access to the world economy.
In 1978, there were, essentially zero private
companies.
All were state-owned, with only a tiny 140,000
people, or 0.01% of its population, employed
privately.
Just three years later, thanks to Mao’s
successor, Deng Xiaoping, that number was
already 16 times higher.
China in the ‘80s and ‘90s was the golden
opportunity to start a company.
Big, inefficient state-owned corporations
had left huge gaps in the economy, people
were moving to the city, finally, with money
to spend, and the government was eager to
encourage enterprise.
Which is to say, Ren Zhengfei couldn’t have
picked a better time than 1987 to start his
company, called Huawei!
A few years later, it won a contract with
the People’s Liberation Army, which, although
small in financial terms, was huge for winning
favor with the Communist Party, who then protected
the company from competition.
With this help, Huawei became, today, the
2nd largest phone company in the world, just
ahead of Apple, and behind only Samsung.
Up until just a few months ago, it was expected
to pass Samsung to become number one, lead
the world in the spread of 5G and gain even
more market share than its current 29% of
all telecommunications equipment on earth.
Then, with one, swift signature, Huawei was
banned.
Not only does this stop the company from selling
equipment in the U.S., but all Huawei products,
everywhere are banned from working with American
companies, who supply Huawei with components
like Intel chips, and software like the Google
Play Store.
So, is Huawei, as the United States claims,
a real threat to national security?
A trojan horse for the Chinese government?
Or is the ban merely political?
The problem with most answers to these questions
is that they focus only on the technology,
the politics, or China.
But to really understand Huawei, you have
to marry all three.
Who really owns a company?
It’s a pretty reasonable question and should
have a pretty simple answer.
You don’t usually need to go around reading
Articles of Incorporation, just some common
sense.
A few decent clues are whoever’s office
is on the 100th floor, or, maybe, whoever’s
business card is most expensive.
But not always.
Because, of course, the structure of a company
is not designed for our legibility, but, rather,
to make more money or limit somebody’s power.
So, you see lots of weird subsidiaries, holding
companies without employees based in the Virgin
Islands, deliberately confusing names, and
dual-class shares.
Things can get… weird.
Take John, for example, of Papa fame, who,
facing public pressure, resigned as the company
chairman.
A few weeks later, John decided actually,
he’d like to return to his pizza Papa position.
The board said, “Yeeeah…
Hard pass!” and changed the company’s
bylaws to block their own largest shareholder
from taking over the company he founded.
He then sued his own company.
One time, a pharmaceutical company called
Rockwell Medical split into two legal corporations,
each claiming to be the real, legitimate Rockwell
Medical Incorporated with the same address
and same shareholders, leaving everyone wondering,
who’s the real pope?
The point is, it’s actually not that simple
of a question.
And, that’s before you add the whole Socialism
twist.
If you do ask Huawei who owns the company,
they’ll happily take you to a special room
in their Shenzhen headquarters, where a giant
blue book, because little and red were taken,
sits behind glass.
Exactly the way you’d expect a multi-billion
dollar tech company to keep its records.
In it, Huawei says, is a list of every person
who owns shares in the company.
And, as they’ll enthusiastically assure
you, none of these people are the Chinese
government.
Case… not closed, obviously.
Here’s what we know:
Huawei Technology LLC is 100% owned by a holding
company called Huawei Investment & Holding,
which is itself owned by two parties:
Huawei’s CEO owns about 1%, and the rest,
the Union of Huawei Investment & Holding.
It says this is only for legal reasons, and,
I’ll remind you, convoluted ownership structures
aren’t at all unusual.
For all practical purposes, Huawei claims,
the company is owned by its employees - the
names in the blue book - who own stock in
the company.
But, again, it’s not so simple.
What Huawei calls stock is, actually, apologizes
in advance to non-business majors, Synthetic
Equity, or, for maximum, put-it-in-the-parking-lot,
synergize, circle-back jargon-points, Restricted
Phantom Shares.
OoOooOoo…
Phantom… spooky sounding!
It’s a lot like regular equity - shareholders,
in this case, Huawei employees, receive a
share of the company’s profits - a dividend.
They stand to make money, so they’re incentivized
to add value to the company.
Except it’s “synthetic” - as in not
totally… real.
It can’t be sold or transferred, doesn’t
give much say in the operations of the company,
and, if an employee, for any reason, leaves
the company, he or she must also sell back
their shares.
As two American researchers summarize “…this
virtual stock ownership has nothing to do
with financing or control.
It is purely a profit-sharing incentive scheme.”
When we ask the question “Who owns Huawei?”,
what we’re really asking is who, if they
really wanted the company to do something,
like, say, spy on foreign countries, has the
power to do so.
The answer, it seems, is the union, who owns
the holding company, who owns the company.
So, who controls the union?
This time the answer is much easier: Under
Chinese labor law, Unions are subject to their
superior branch - local Unions answer to provincial
unions, all the way up through a winding python
of hierarchy, ending at the chairman of the
All-China Federation of Trade Unions, who
also sits on the National People's Congress.
Unions in China are, therefore, largely an
extension of the Communist Party.
Now, you’d be right to point out that this
alone shouldn’t be enough to ban an entire
company from doing business with an entire
country.
After all, this logic applies to many Chinese
companies, not just Huawei.
It would be ridiculous to ban all of them.
To that, defenders of the ban would say, But
Huawei is no ordinary company; it has a long
history of alleged misbehavior.
It’s CFO was, quite prominently, arrested
in Canada on the grounds of violating US sanctions
on Iran.
Cisco accused the company of copying their
manuals after finding the same typos in Huawei’s,
which its CEO said was just a coincidence.
The CIA also claims it has evidence that Huawei
has taken money from Chinese intelligence
services.
And finally, in 2012, China gave the African
Union a new $200 million headquarters in Ethiopia.
Then, last year, a French newspaper quoted
anonymous technicians in the building who
claimed they caught Huawei equipment copying
and sending data to servers in Shanghai - which
China and the African Union officially deny.
On one hand, there’s a lot of smoke here,
on the other, there’s also a lot of people
who have a strong interest in you believing
there’s a fire.
All of these incidents are alleged, and, neither
the UK nor the US has ever presented clear
evidence of a backdoor in Huawei equipment,
despite having many years to investigate.
Before the ban, before its phones were cut-off
from Google services, before it lost its relationship
with ARM, before it was, indirectly, forced
to sell off its undersea cable business, Huawei
was unstoppable.
Experts tend to agree that it’s years ahead
of anyone else on 5G technology and that its
equipment is, in general, significantly cheaper.
That’s why, despite pressure from its allies,
Britain has continued buying Huawei equipment
- doing so saves, at least, millions of dollars.
It mirrors the predicament many countries
around the world face with Chinese investment:
Even knowing the risk of dependence on China,
can they resist the economic benefits?
It’s no secret that, while this is going
on, the U.S. is in a trade war with China,
and banning Huawei gives it both negotiating
leverage and protects American telecommunications
companies from foreign competition, exactly
at its strongest.
So, make no mistake: The ban is political.
It’s been strongly hinted as being on the
table for trade negotiations.
And it’s quite possible the ban will soon
be reversed if a deal is made.
But, it’s just as important to note that
just because something is strategically motivated,
doesn’t mean there aren’t, other, perfectly
legitimate arguments.
Much of the confusion around this issue is
centered around the fact that politicians
can agree on the same policy for vastly different
reasons.
The truth is you don’t need to make a judgment
call on whether you trust Huawei or its CEO.
You only need to recognize the most basic
feature of the Chinese system: everything
is the concern of the state.
From what is shown on TV, to who is allowed
to travel, even how long you can play Fornite,
and certainly the movements of its largest
corporations, the Communist Party is everywhere,
if not now, and quite possibly, not, in the
case of Huawei, eventually.
Having an enemy is, unfortunately, useful
for American politicians, especially one as
misunderstood as China,
but so too is it crucial for a country to
keep its communications infrastructure, through
which national secrets are shared and information
wars, increasingly fought, free from foreign
influence.
This is much bigger than any one company,
bigger than who controls 5G, bigger even than
the trade-war.
It’s really about the Chinese system being
used against it.
The story of Huawei is very much the story
of China - both only realized their full potential
upon opening up to the world’s markets,
where Huawei now makes the much of its revenue,
and how China was turned into one of the most
powerful nations on earth.
Huawei is what it is today to a significant
degree because of its close relationship with
and subsequent protection by the Chinese government.
Now, it’s a victim of that same closeness
- the other side of that very profitable coin,
which, ironically, has long blocked many western
tech companies - Google, Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube… - from operating in China on, you
guessed it… national security grounds.
China would like the benefits of free, open
trade abroad, while closely protecting and
controlling business domestically.
But now it’s forced to chose.
In a trade war like this one, each side is
trying to use game theory to interpret and
outmaneuver their opponent, who may or may
not be lying.
For example, say there are two types of people
- knights, who always tell the truth, and
knaves, who always lie.
You say “If I asked if you were a knight,
what would you say”? and they respond “No”,
which are they - knight or knave?
To see the answer and solve other problems
like this one, check out the interactive logic,
computer science, and math courses on Brilliant.
You can even do them offline with their iOS
and Android apps.
If you want something more bite-sized, Brilliant
also has Daily Challenges in math, science,
and engineering.
You can use the link in the description to
start learning for free, and the first 200
people will get 20% off the annual premium
subscription, so you can view all Daily Challenges
and unlock dozens of problem-solving courses.
Thanks again to Brilliant and to you for watching
this video.